um my name is pim i'm here today with
robin uh robin is one of our founding
engineers and i'm the founder of stream
privacy we are building a product that
makes it very easy to be confident about
privacy and quickly launch data
pipelines and we think that has a lot of
advantages today we'll take you through
sort of the story and the learnings that
we have we hope you walk away with a few
very concrete points
in how you can build privacy by design
or bring privacy by design to you or to
your data
um
it is
not
yeah there we are
um so first the story how we actually uh
got to learn that then we'll dive into a
architecture
as an example which is uh how we are
built
and then as a quick demo um and the
solution that uh that we think uh brings
privacy by design to data
so
i'd like to take you back to uh may 25
2018. so we're from europe uh this is a
key date if you're in data in europe
because it's the implementation date of
gdpr it became effective as of now we
were at a large schemers marketplace
building the streaming data platform and
applied machine learning and
we weren't too worried about privacy
we're just building cool stuff but this
came up and then there was a lawyer
seven weeks in advance that told us you
can't do recommendations anymore and no
recommendations at a marketplace is sort
of painful
so that got our attention got senior
management attention as well and there
was a start of seven weeks of trying to
reprocess 18 years of data that didn't
even fit into the data center um it's a
story for another talk actually
it was also the start of learning how to
translate a very vague legislation into
very concrete data system implications
this is four years ago almost four years
ago
and if you look at the state of privacy
or the cost of privacy right now we
haven't gotten really far
the sort of true implications of privacy
are right now that it takes a lot of
coordination to make sure systems are
privacy ready or privacy safe
i think we're all worried about the
utility that we can keep in data we have
a fun talk right after ours about how to
retain the utility um but they're sort
of like this ghost if you need to do
privacy you will lose the usefulness of
your data we think that's not true but
that's still what we run into quite a
lot
and because there's such a big gap
between
the policy perspective and the data and
engineering perspective the real
responsibility like does your lawyer
understand data probably not quite they
can draft agreements and they can write
a lot of stuff but it's different from
building it inside data so like atlas
who carried the world on the shoulders
data teams carry the real responsibility
for privacy
this means that in practice there's
basically no standard there is a
standard which is employed by
many vendors and i think inside many
organizations and that's just
restricting access like okay oh you you
have role i well you cannot access a
specific column and that's how we deal
with privacy but actually that's way too
late it's not way too late or it is not
just way too late from the policy
perspective it's way too late in general
because privacy starts at the point of
data collection
so these are basically sort of the five
principles that we distilled in those
seven weeks of awesome learning
about how to bring privacy by design to
data and the very first thing i know
there's quite some stuff going on about
discovering
data patterns discovering data structure
automatically but when talking about
privacy you need to know what your data
is you need to make your structure very
very explicit we call them data
contracts we'll get to that
the next point is what i already
mentioned is okay thinking about data
privacy as soon as you have
data is too late you need to shift left
shift left you need to shift to the
point of data collection where data
actually starts living because and this
is a key concept
in i think any privacy legislation
anywhere around the world
you need to know what you can do with
data you need to know the purpose
consent is a very simple example can i
use this for marketing purposes can i
use this for personalization purposes or
perhaps i can't use it at all because i
um i got to acquire the data point on
some kind of legal ground like i need to
fulfill a contract so it's a very narrow
definition of what you can do with data
you need to move it all the way to the
beginning of your stack
the next problem comes if you don't know
what your data is then you also don't
know what you need to do in terms of
processing so you need to apply the
privacy transform before you do anything
else so we're not even talking data
warehouses we're just talking data
collection and immediately at that point
convert the data into
useful data from the privacy perspective
you need to define purpose binded stream
so that is i have this data point
collected under a marketing purpose so
let's make sure that we can only use it
for cases that fit that specific purpose
and
because we have very complex stacks and
we're running all sorts of tools you
need to make it interoperable and fast
so we're streaming based that's not
because we're religious about streaming
we are but that's not the reason
it's because if you remove any latency
constraints right at the beginning you
can run any system
downstream anything you still have be it
batch be it another streaming flight
frame it doesn't it doesn't matter it
gets agnostic
so let's break that down those are the
five principles
diving into the technical point of view
um the first step like we said this is
basically a process step this is you the
data team agreeing with the legal team
or
someone involved with policy how you
will actually use and collect the data
and how it should be processed
and like i said that takes data
structure explicit data structure we
call them data contracts a data contract
falls apart is a very simple concept we
have a shape which what we all do is
schema registry okay this is field one
field two field three and they have
specific types
but it's also a description of the
privacy implications of each field so a
very simple example would be a user id
if i'm running analytics i don't need
user id per se i might be i might want
to retain some kind of pattern so i need
to apply
a masking function to the field of user
id for specific purposes
and in the data contract the field has a
sort of level a purpose level
that is described uh very
very concise very strictly uh in how it
should be transformed later on so this
is just simply the agreement stage you
can register these contracts
and that's the start that's why you
think about what are the privacy
implications of what we do
if we move on and robin will uh will now
take over for the architecture and a
small demo as well then the question
becomes once we have that but we have
this description once we have the
definition how to actually do the
processing
it's the green one
all right
thanks pim
um yeah so i'll move on now to
an example architecture on how to
actually implement implement these
principles that pim just discussed
so what you see in this example
architecture is it all starts with
applications sending data
so these applications they send data to
a so-called
gatekeeper
and this gatekeeper the purpose of this
is at first
that it enforces the data contract that
bim just mentioned
second it does validations on the
content of the events that are being
sent
and lastly it
applies the anonymization to the
sensitive data fields
the result of this process is a
stream which is anonymized and can be
used actually by anyone within your
organization
so
what happens if you want the
de-anonymized form of the data
well then you can actually apply privacy
transformations to
get the original form of the data back
but
you of course want to make distinction
between the various levels so
a end user
provided consent for his data to be used
in a specific purpose and you want to
respect that so you will only get
the the anonymized versions of the data
for which the end user provided the
consent and that's because this consent
is actually embedded into the events
themselves
so the end result here is that we have
purpose binded interfaces which can be
exposed to data consumers in various
ways
here you see a websocket for example at
the top which we'll see in our demo
this of course is all nice but
we do need a good tooling around this
and that's why we offer a web interface
and a good cli to interact and manage
these
these streams
and of course like bim already mentioned
you want to be able to use your existing
data stack
and that's why we integrate with
many of the tools you'll probably know
and already love
so let's not try to replace that
moving on to the demo so the purpose of
the demo is that
we do visualizations in in real time
based on these privacy streams so the
stream that i just mentioned in
the architecture
we're going to use that actually to do a
real-time visualization
what we did is we took a data set from
kaggle of a large spanish bank
and
what we did at first was to create a
data contract
on this data
the second part is that we created a
simulator that replays over this data
and actually simulates a live click
stream
and the last part is actually the the
visualization itself
note that all this is done using the
anonymized form of the data so we still
respect the end user consent
um
well to not test the democrats
[Music]
we made a
video
and what we do at the beginning
is actually create this data contract
so the data contract is composed of two
components of which the first one is the
shape the schema and the second one is
the contract which
defines
the sensitive data fields the pii fields
uh it does more but
the purpose of this demo is aimed at
that part
so um while we wait up for that to be
finished we can also inspect it and
actually it's it's tied directly to the
schema so together it makes up a a full
data contract
here you can also see the sense the data
fields mentioned under pii fields
and the last part here is that we need
to create a stream to which we can send
events
um this will present us with credentials
and these credentials can then be used
for our simulator to actually start
sending data which you see over here
next step
is
actually viewing the data
via the websocket interface meant for
debug purposes and we see data flowing
through
important part here is that not
everything is anonymized only the fields
that mentioned are mentioned in a data
contract are anonymized
we can view a single event and at the
top we see meta information which
actually
defines the consent provided for this
single event
um
this part is actually
another
representation of the data simplified
version and you see everything passing
by okay nice uh next step uh is that we
actually create pairs of data which
represent page transitions between web
pages on the spanish bank site
then we can do counts on these pairs to
actually see and visualize these page
transitions and present them in uh
yeah a visual representation shown on
the left a force directed graph here
um okay what do you have uh with that
well um you can see funnels on your
website so you can actually see how
people move on your website and
the end goal here is for example to
actually predict what the next page will
be to help your customers on your
website to move to
the path that they need to go to
faster that wraps up the demo
note that
it's it's done using the anonymized form
of the data so we really respect the end
user consent
bim back to you
yeah thanks um so
that's we think a pretty cool use case
because it allows you to expose for
instance a
real time next pass action model to
users that you don't necessarily need to
know anything about or have consent on
that's the cool thing about
anonymization or the identification you
can actually use the data for different
purposes then you obtained it and that's
just one of the use cases that we see so
this would be basically an input feature
to a model that you would build and
expose yourself there's tons of other
stuff that that we see users and
customers working on
operational analytics and
immobility is a cool one like something
like scooters a location data point is
completely insensitive uh but if you
have a day of data it's suddenly
incredibly
insensitive because it could expose
where someone lives and where someone
works that's a
very easy case one identification
problem there's a lot of health
applications um when does someone go
into cardiac arrest you would like to
know that in a certain time window uh
thank you
so that really helps to
process all the data and use immediately
um and one of the key things and this is
actually what we sort of so we started
to solve a technical problem and we're
discovering that basically privacy is a
process problem more than just
technology that is that it helps to
structure the privacy discussions inside
companies so you put the legal and the
data team uh at a table they agree on
what can be done with data and that's
the only discussion you're having the
rest is just build and expose what you
would like to build and expose
so the summary in terms of how to bring
privacy by design to your data make sure
you insert privacy
before anything else
encode the privacy policies through data
contracts
align the privacy policies and the
processing in one go distribute what we
call privacy stream purpose-driven
interfaces
and you can do this all in real time if
necessary but if you start with real
time it's easy to go batch
that's it
thank you